Trees inherently aren't
really organized.
When we use a tree, we know what
the overall structure looks like, but
we don't know where
a specific element will be.
It turns out that we can add some rules
about the ordering of elements to our
trees to accomplish
certain tasks really fast.
In the coming videos,
we'll talk about some common tree types
with specific rules regarding
the ordering of elements.
As we go, don't let yourself get so
caught up in understanding the types of
trees that you forget the big picture.
When would you want to
use these structures?
What tasks would they speed up?
What are the pros and
cons of each approach?